when you read 110 to 115 000 comic books
a lot of it sticks and then some of it
you know someone will ask me a question
i was like boy i know i read that and i
have
very little recollection of it which
tells me that it was kind of a
middle-of-the-road comic
i'm bob bretol and i collect comic books
and related
ephemera
i have somewhere north of 120 000 at
this point that's not the number in the
record book but i'm working on
transferring my stuff to a new debate
database and i'll be updating my
guinness number
hopefully by the end of the year from
the moment that i started reading him
when i was eight years old it just i got
sucked into that world and it was just
you know kind of a connect the dots of
all these different things where i went
from one thing to another but
i just kept reading them and i read them
to this day there are collectors out
there and you know they have a very
limited definition of comics or they
really haven't bothered looking around
at what's available because there are a
tremendous number of good comics
have been published throughout the whole
time i've been reading them i try to
make stuff
kind of logically fit together i kind of
made an art gallery out of this stuff
these are all original art pages a lot
of art today is done
digitally
but back in the day
they would do it black and white on
these 11 by 14 art boards and the
lettering would be right on it and then
they would reproduce that
and reduce it and then they would do
coloring guides
off of that so i've collected art over
the years i have two older brothers and
they're quite a bit older than me like
eight and ten years older than me
so there were always comics around when
i was little i remember reading some
uncle scrooge comics or richie rich or
there'd be a batman or some other kind
of
superhero comics when i was eight
my brother my older brother russ gave me
a coupon that he made you know just that
was good for 10 comic books because i
had kind of liked to read his comics and
i think he wanted me to stay away from
his comics so he's like if you go to the
store and buy comic book and come back
and show it to me i'll mark one of the
slots on the coupon off and give you the
15 cents back they cost 15 cents then
when i was a little kid
entertainment options were very limited
for me as an eight-year-old i would
cut the characters out of my comic books
to make little paper dolls and i would
have
adventures and spider-man would fight
daredevil and i would do all kinds of
fun things with them and of course i
destroyed
a lot of
my earliest comics by cutting the
characters out of my comic books this is
a spider-man that i cut out of some
early issue of spider-man that i had
when i was probably eight or nine years
old i had
collected over the years
all the issues of spider-man but i
didn't have his first appearance which
was an amazing fantasy 15 and which was
always a fairly expensive comic
around the time i got the record
i decided i was going to buy
amazing fantasy 15. over the last
51 years
i've bought every comic book that i have
pretty much individually not
individually because
i get like
30 or 40 comic new comics a week so i'm
still buying lots of comics
but i buy all these comics myself i buy
them kind of one at a time and i read
them all
if you've never read a comic
and you think that comics are only
superheroes they're not
and
you know if you're interested all in the
medium and not everybody is but just
that
the
combination of art and story i just love
it and some people that's going to click
with and other people it won't but it's
really worth
trying out a comic book and it doesn't
have to be a superhero comic book you
can go to a comic book store and get
all different kinds of things and
there's you know so many different kinds
of comics and just see if it's
entertaining
you